hello how are you good late sorry okay
we were trying to figure out Bert and
Ernie yeah oh yeah they're fighting over
some things that have no genitals so
that's why I tried this there's no
answer are they homosexual yes I don't
know you'd have to have genitals to be
anything yeah so what's the thing yeah
but of course people will fight over
puppets being gay because you know
that's where we live right now even the
people who are like well no because
homosexuality is a mentality it's cool
that's fine they have no brains either
they're just property there's no there's
no brains or genitals so it's
unbelievable yeah so there's you know
they weren't they don't really dress
that well I really don't think they're
the other you know think gay people wear
the same clothes every day for 40 years
yeah that just never happened it's never
happened no it wouldn't
no it wouldn't happen it makes no sense
the hair is pretty good I don't know
Barbie Sam's you and you as well but I
mean as far as stand-up this guy Jimmy
but it's weird you've been hearing about
somebody and hearing your name for 25
years I know but all comics feel like
you know everyone thinks we live in a
big house together
yeah which we actually do yeah and it
feels like I mean I feel like I know
you'll feel like we've had to admit but
I'm sure we haven't and you you are the
first that you were the first woman to
have a special which is really
interesting that you had to push them
for that I didn't push them I had to do
it myself I mean I begged for two years
it was never gonna happen and I met a
guy who was a really good producer and
director and he said you know if you
have any money at all we can do this and
I had a tiny little bit no credit cards
I was so young and we did it and they
still what is what is a tiny little bit
at $10,000 in the bank and those days
owes those specials were costing 350,000
and I had been at stand-up for 12 years
I had a little apartment that I rented I
had nothing you know and $10,000 was
twelve years of savings and stand-up in
those days and you said we're going
all-in yeah all in you know where'd you
shoot it bottom line in New York okay
remember that was just yeah I knew the
club I don't work there but no wow that
was a great club yeah that went that
close that was pretty sad what years
were you at The Improv
I was the doorman from 73 to 76 I was
Dan
yellow was the doorman before me good
actor and then he quit and I became the
doorman first I was a waitress when they
realized I couldn't carry anything
successfully I said there's gotta be
something you could do here where you
don't carry things so I had the best too
in New York and did that for three so
you would see like Pryor coming in and
out of there God yeah I mean I think I
got good fast because I was there seven
nights a week from 6:00 till 4:00 in the
morning and I had to stand there and I I
mean I can still do every act I've ever
seen because I saw them over and over
again and it just made me really good my
wasn't gonna be a comic or anything it's
nothing you know you aimed for in those
days it just was one of those things you
know got fired from all the A's and the
B's got to the C stand get fired that
was it comedy right oh she started to
understand after you were there for a
long time yeah you know I was 20 and it
was 1973 you know you didn't look at
Rodney Dangerfield on on The Tonight
Show and say oh that's what I want to be
he just didn't exist right was just an
app but when I walked in you know in
those days it was the purview of the old
you know was old hangdog husbands older
women complained you know it was all one
thing and I had never seen a young
version of it and I walked into that
club to be a waitress and there was
Richard Lewis and Freddie Prinze and
Andy Kaufman and Richard Belzer and
Jimmy Walker it was incredible and he
ran Mike Preminger II was great writer
then an Edie bluestone who's the genius
of life he he had the biggest-selling
National Lampoon cover of all time it
was in those days and it was a dog
looking at a gun sideways and right
right right if you don't like this
magazine will shoot this dog photo so it
took a long time but he was a genius I
walked in and it was these young guys
you know in their 20s going will you
ever notice I went yeah I always noticed
that and I realized here someone
speaking to me and it was a whole other
world of what this artform could be it
was Freddie Prinze like I don't talk to
her I know a lot people who fryer we're
Carla I don't know a lot of you I knew
Freddie Prinze I knew Friday real well
he was still in high school I used to
drive him home to Washington Heights and
he was 18 when he came in and I remember
I got a
some food the first night and he came
over and he had like a little bag of pot
and he said can I pay you and there
suddenly said only if he'll buy it back
for me he was the sweetest kindest he
was a kid he was just a kid and I think
you know his downfall was when we all
idolized Lenny Bruce in those days but
Freddie wanted to be Lenny Bruce and and
sadly he kind of was he just was so yeah
I think he died at 22 yeah and you know
he just was too smitten with but even
like right before he died I ran into him
at The Improv in LA and he was crossing
the street and he was so loaded getting
into his you know gorgeous midnight blue
Corvette and he turned her on you said
hey booze that bit you did and I thought
wow he's still like right on it you know
and it's just why did he shoot himself
was it was he depressed over drugs no
relationships an accident he and his
friends played Russian roulette all the
time I really believe I mean those of us
who knew him pretty well we don't think
he meant to kill himself that night and
especially because when you shoot
yourself from your heels you put the gun
in your mouth because then you die but
he it was in the side of his head and
that's why he didn't die right away
you know that's the Russian Roulette
thing if you're really gonna kill
yourself you always eat the gun because
it blows your brains out the best sorry
guys if you're eating breakfast but you
might be opposed to I have my water
that's fine so you think he was loaded
and playing Russian roulette I do and a
lot of his friends who were close to him
you know he was had such a charmed life
I don't think he ever thought he was
gonna lose and that or he was loaded and
not even playing Russian roulette just
too loaded to know what the hell he was
doing right I do not think he meant to
kill himself that night and those of us
who knew him don't think so either so
there wasn't this thing even when you
saw him like later and he was getting
into the car and he was all drunk it
wasn't like this sort of sad like oh
what's happened to no not at all I mean
he's 22 he's the most beautiful creature
on earth six feet that face gorgeous you
know happy like on it yeah you know he
was so aware of everything you know and
um I just think he got loaded and didn't
know he was gonna kill himself that man
you know he did last a while a couple of
day or a day maybe but it was terrible I
mean you know look
I guess your fade is our fade it's not
like if that's your time that was that
was it what are you gonna do and when
you would see like all these guys coming
through like it like Andy Kaufman I
guess you would watch him work through
things and do people before he did taxi
and people didn't know who he was what
was it like to watch him go onstage
where he was not famous
well at first what we lived together for
two and half years in the village he was
like the love of my life so you know
that was
yeah he's the reason they do this and
blame him if you hate me do you think
you're gonna marry him um oh god no no I
was 20 years old he was 25 um no but he
saw me sing they made us sing in between
the comics so people could have a chance
to talk and order we were so bad and I
mean literally I'd be on stage doing Van
Morrison's Moondance and I would yell
see if these two in the front I go well
it's about right here please night for a
moon and some butter okay with the stars
you know it's just hilarious just to do
because you're trying to like do
something where the people can actually
be talking to the staff without being a
problem and interrupting the comedian
yeah exactly so he just threw that every
waitress had to sing so I learned three
songs so I could sing oh you weren't
onstage you were actually just served
are you are okay hostess and I still had
to go onstage and sing so so I know you
don't know how bad you are at anything
at the beginning so you know and I said
and he was like we were starting to date
and I said you have to see me sing you
have to see me sing so finally one night
at timed-out where he did come in and I
was singing and I came off and he was
looking down and I said well I was young
and he said oh you know when something
so terribly did he like when he wouldn't
get laughs I mean it like I've seen him
what did digress from your question
going one of my favorite YouTube clips
is it's Andy Kaufman and he goes onstage
and he eats a bowl of vanilla ice cream
and he gets served like the waitress has
to come up
he orders he sits there he doesn't say
anything he just like he's just sitting
there
if he's in the audience then she gives
him his vanilla ice cream and then he
sits there eating it no jokes
yeah and then he finishes the ice cream
and then he splits he's done yeah and
like it people are just like what the
[ __ ] like what what just happened is
that what he was looking for um you know
gosh I well he was a genius he worked on
a different kind of level of
consciousness than anybody had been
doing TM meditating for like ten years
already by then and he was on such a
different plane and his thing was
literally he called himself a children's
entertainer if you said comedian he
wouldn't come up you know which he told
me if they say comedian people are gonna
feel compelled to laugh and I said well
I'll make sure they say comedian when
it's my turn but the pressure on please
make them but he really he just wanted
to take you everywhere and when you
asked me before you know when before
they knew him from taxi first of all he
didn't do to his thing for taxi was he
wouldn't be on more than once a month
because he didn't want to become just
that so he wasn't that no one from taxi
yet even at the beginning and they
adapted his foreign man character to be
the Latka character on taxi they came to
him because of what he was doing but
what he did for people literally if he
was done after his hour and you just
brought a focus group in to look at the
audience and say okay what have these
people just been through and you would
look at them they're you know soaked
literally they were like laying
prostrate you know on it you'd say what
just happened to these hundred and fifty
people I think the focus group would say
oh they just got off a roller coaster
right and that's really the joy of he
you know I know we're meaner now but he
had no meanness in him and no meanness
in the act and it wasn't to get
something over on the audience it was to
take them through every single human
emotion by the end of that hour and he
did and you know you'd watch them I mean
I stood in the back it was the most
amazing thing I've ever seen every night
and literally at the end they were so
delighted you know how when you're going
up the first Hill on the roller coast
you go why am I doing this why am I
doing this oh my god oh my god and then
it hits he goes you know
but oh no and then at the end you go we
have to ride again we have to ride again
that was AMD's me I was Andy that was
seeing Andy like oh my god what just
happened that was amazing
and just the delight he left them they
were all five years old after you know
the thing about I respect about him is
the fact that he did it in front of an
audience that wasn't always ready for it
like he didn't do any specialty rooms
that they have I mean everything is
specialty now I have anything right
we're no room it was the improv really
wasn't even we didn't even have catch
yet in 73 The Improv was this hole in
the wall in Hell's Kitchen when it was
Hell's Kitchen and um you know you'd
have like three Japanese tourists and a
couple of hookers came in to rest their
feet and it wasn't like people came to
see comedy literally every comic there
all those young guys I mentioned had a
day job it was totally a hobby it was
like jazz or you know reading poetry in
the village it wasn't a thing and you
there was no circuit to go on you were
either the biggest star in the world
you know headlining the Copa and Vegas
or with the TV show or you were nobody
who had a day job and didn't make a
penny so the main thing was people would
get on The Tonight Show to see if they
could you know break through that
barrier of either becoming a known
nightclub comic or a TV you know sitcom
guy and that was all there watch there
was no place to go so there was no
schedule now it's like you have six
minutes you have one minute you have two
minutes you you know there was a couple
of guys and I wish the hostess and in
the winter they didn't even comic us it
was snowing and that's why I got so good
so fast because sometimes I had to be
there to unlock the door so sometimes I
was on for two hours just talking
onstage to the people because nobody
came yet you know Richard Lewis ain't
coming out honest and no Larry David was
also one of they certainly wasn't coming
out in a in a snowstorm on a Tuesday at
11 o'clock so I was the go-to and it was
it was trial by fire but of course
looking back how lucky right yeah you
were there for all that so you would
watch Pryor Korean and work stuff out oh
my god he you know it's funny when Tyson
you know who I like Mike Tyson I really
do but you know before we knew to like
him when he was just the scary right
right um I was watching someone talk
about boxing and he said you know Tyson
is
is kind of an aberration to the boxing
world all the boxers from from since
time began were the gentlest souls in
real life they were the kindest gentlest
and I thought wow that's so interesting
you know and I think like the comics who
really are the genius comics had they
have two streaks in him but one is that
gentle Pryor yes he shot a car and he
had 19 wives but they were such a
sweetness and a gentleness in this man I
don't know if I'm just talking your ears
oh no no I'm interested you have a good
story it's wrong oh yeah no these are
nice so you know when you really knew
you think you're good because you're an
idiot or you would never do it again
yeah so of course God has to protect it
it's a new people right so I thought I
was good I'd been doing it for 15
minutes so really I had nothing and so I
was emceeing which I did every night
because there's nobody there and you
know once bud knew that I was reliable
he just showed up later and later so
Pryor comes in so I seat him with this
party you know for people and I'm
supposed to bring up the next comic and
of course being a horrible human being
instead of bringing them right up I go
into my quote unquote act a little bit
and I am dying like a dog I mean it is
the worst and you know really if you
would knew anything you wouldn't want to
do a 15-minute old act that you just
figured out in front of Richard Pryor
you wouldn't but you know we're idiots
so I'm doing that are you trying to
impress him yes exactly
Pryor and you know it's getting worse
and worse and worse and I'm actually
losing inches and height it was just so
horrible and finally I said was a flop
sweat oh my god anyway so I finally
realized the act of standing on this
side just kind of enjoying the fact that
I screwed him and now I'm dying you know
well he should Jim would you enjoy
something seeing something like that I I
wasn't there and I'm enjoying it thirty
years later I'm enjoying it you're
enjoying it forty-six oh my god
I know I look really young but
hello radio yeah so so you're bombing
while this guy's watching you die now to
be fair I might not have done it to a
guy I respected but this guy was a very
well-known thief and I thought I have no
qualms about punishing him a little bit
because you know he's terrible you would
say something in the bar and he'd go on
and do it you know he was such a thief
and was it oh no I can you know he's not
performing no no no reason lying someone
46 years but and he happen to be a nice
guy but he was it was almost like a
sickness you would say anything or eat
here you go in over your stuff and he
just go up he couldn't help himself so
anyway so I'm dying I'm dying and I
think I gotta get it you know in the
audience just like we hope you die we
want you to really die it's an
aggressive bombing so I get to this
sentence and I'll always remember it I
said well how about a nice big hand for
so-and-so and Pryor stands up he's in
the very back of the room and he says
hey how about a hand for you mama and he
just starts clapping and he makes the
whole audience clap and I just went ok
I'll go wash his car for the charity at
that point it was totally he was the
goodwill of comedy at that moment it was
you know I'm a little charity that that
note of of gentleness I was so I watched
the Jim Carey Andy Kaufman documentary
big Andy Kaufman fan but it bugged me I
thought it was really interesting just
watching a guy kind of going to method
like a maniac
pleasure it bunked me because every
story that I've ever heard from people
who actually knew Andy yeah was that
this guy who was a total [ __ ] on
camera and all these sort of
over-the-top stories was not even sort
of the guy that was off camera so I'm
watching Jim Carrey Lake Drive everybody
on set crazy and he an [ __ ] that's
not Andy that and I was like Jim is just
do
ship gym or TV Andy or whatever that's
not well behind the scenes Andy right
you know no absolutely right right clean
and and mainly when people do things
people they didn't know it's mostly
about them
I haven't there's nothing that has done
Andy justice in my opinion I've
cooperated with nothing none of the
books none of the specials none of the
movies nothing I never sold him out I
didn't want to hand the the gold I know
over to people that didn't know him or
maybe less gifted you know I thought
when I write my book you know and it'll
be 46 years later I'll tell all the
great stories I I did write one
beautiful piece when he died I didn't
know what to do with the grief and so I
just sat down and wrote and wrote and
wrote you know he's just so young and I
just took my little you know badly typed
months of writing because I just didn't
know where to put them the grief and I
just took little envelopes and looked up
you know there was no internet or
anything it was 1980 you know 84 and I
just found a little you know go to the
newsstand and look for where you'd send
to these magazines and I sent everything
out and they all wrote back and said
this is great but we already did our
Andy piece you know and I didn't care
anyway Esquire said we're gonna pay Phil
Berger a kill fee and buy this piece
because it's so beautiful and so it did
run and you know I'm so proud of it it's
it's very old now but you know it the
best lay I got a lot of mail and the
nicest letter said you know I never got
this guy didn't know why I should like
him but what you've done is made me love
him without giving away his secrets and
that's how I treat him and you know the
book that'll come out eventually it's
just how the wonder of him without you
know anything that he wouldn't want out
you know so you didn't like the Milosz
Forman movie either I didn't like oh man
in the moon no really how come for a
million reasons let's just say that but
you know what that's just show business
they have to make it you know much more
dramatic and make the guy sick or crazy
my husband built the doors into the
doors he managed the doors he was 20
they were older than he was he literally
took a band no one ever heard of and
turned them into the doors and we went
and watched the doors movie and he went
yeah did he find it to be an accurate
portrayal
you know that's what I'm trying to tell
you just like when the show vinyl came
out on HBO everyone in the music
business threw up in their living room
like what what about the Showtime show
do the I'm dying up here show
the point is it's very hard to watch
your own profession and I was walking my
dog in Central Park when the movie
punchline came out and I always get
recognized in New York cuz you know it's
scary where I am and so I start talking
to this policeman in the end we're
talking he said so would you think a
punch line I said yeah you know it's not
quite accurate and he said oh oh it's
not accurate about your profession is
that what you're saying and I said yeah
anyway miss boos let me ask you a
question do you know how often a
policeman takes his gun out in a 35 year
career and I said how often he said
never
I guess you watch your own job and
you're like god I mean to a lesser
extent it's like like the movie talk
radio where you're watching that was
realistic
you mean when he's hopefully the end of
it will be when he's walking around the
room he's not even talking into a
microphone this is just a genius smoking
and talking like wow that's compelling
[ __ ] headphones on idiot I don't
typically I don't watch a lot of stuff
like that but uh have you heard the
characters based on you the blonde in it
yeah here's the thing the book you know
it had the overall feel correct but but
every detail was so completely wrong I
mean the facts were so not fact that my
friend Diane Nichols who's a great comic
started when I did we had a drinking
game of like the fact you know what's
wrong in it and we didn't even get like
past ten pages we just fell off that
chairs and died you know so wrong and
the thing that's bothersome is that a I
let him record talking to him and it's
the only book I ever cooperated with
because I thought he was talking about
the strike and not us and B he was a
reporter for the LA Times so you really
should take your news with a grain of
salt because if he can get something
meaningless wrong like you know just
common right sure then what about the
newsman so it's like you know so much
was wrong and eat the little things add
up to make it kind of like now this is
off but as far as the show goes mo he's
glad to see
good friends get work like ever go over
to news and you know great great guy and
so I'm happy about that
what are you is that doesn't strike
there's 82 it was eighty nineteen eighty
and the legendary guy that jumped off
relieve Lou beckon all right yeah that
story well the strike was going on and
on and it was terrible and then she
started punishing everyone who you know
strategy yeah she wouldn't let them back
in and he you know he just lost heart he
couldn't get back in and he jumped in
the nationís pocket said you know my
name is Steve Lou Becca and I used to
work at the Comedy Store
look obviously strikes not gonna make
you kill yourself unless you're you know
we you know get some issues but it was
very sad it was off the hotel next door
jumped off the roof inches I guess
didn't hit like the parking lot who came
tried to hit the parking lot the Comedy
Store
yeah well it's there attached so alright
that's a legendary story yeah yeah I
would say you definitely have issues
outside have to it pretty much ended the
strike though we were still striking and
then he you know kind of like
negotiating and all that and that kind
of just put it all aside and people just
stopped fighting how did that affect her
well I think she it made her stop you
know she just started okay well do this
will do this will do this so you know
what broke my heart the other night I
was at the store and just going on and
so this really nice girl was talking she
wouldn't yeah you guys you know you
fought for money in the big room but we
were in the little room we don't get
anything I said
are you insane we fought for the little
room there was no big room we killed
ourselves for the libman we never got
back in we never got a penny of that
money but do you know that now I've
learned and and it's true I'm saying it
on the air if you work the main room at
the Comedy Store
you know weekends for a month you can
make $4,000 a month that's what we
struck we struck for $1 is set and now
you can come home with four grams a
month and never leave town and and have
that so we did strike and it did work
yeah that's funny that somebody comes
and especially now with all the
different revenue streams of balance
yeah yeah I can goes you guys do fights
like shut the [ __ ] you make your money
you shut up that's the only thing that
bothers me about comedians now is they
don't there's no history for them to go
look at right you know you're a baseball
player you watch Ty Cobb you know you
watch Babe Ruth I watch them for social
cues I cop
that guy do you know who I think is very
underrated can everybody talk about
prior in the cupboard Carla I mean
Robert Klein comedians know is so great
but I always thought Robert Klein was
very underrated he wasn't in this time
so that's what I would think back then
no but used to go see him in you know
Carnegie Hall and Philharmonic Hall he
and Pryor were the only two playing
those venues and he was incredible I
think he had an amazing run an HBO still
loves someone constantly gives him show
so that but I understand what he did but
who isn't that rarefied air yeah it's
like a handful it's Pryor Lenny Bruce
Lord Buckley and you know maybe Lily
Tomlin I mean not maybe Lily Tom and
lily and when who would you put in there
didn't he love her he was amazing he
loved her too Byron Lily yeah they did
specials together they were amazing yeah
I mean that kind of talent recognizes
each other and I don't think that a lot
of fun playing off characters like you
guys so you know it's a nice thing when
you hear like this generation of comics
kind of getting like oh my god
this is the the new way of doing
business they're producing their own
specials yeah cuz you hear that now it's
like I you know Louie did it and now a
bunch of the guys at Netflix in blah
blah blah
Andrew Schultz Andrew Sean some pieces
on special just put it on YouTube
because nobody picked it up are you
going yeah I did that decades ago that's
doing it because it's a great thing now
yeah and they do better with it I did it
cuz I was forced to do it right I mean
literally I had been on the road for 12
years I was doing a two and a half hours
show I was on the road 50 weeks here and
I still have the reviews they say this
was the longest and best show we ever
had here two and a half hours and I
didn't even live anywhere I was on the
road 50 weeks here I'm not exaggerating
and I would go up to HBO when he showed
him they go look nobody wants to see a
woman do an hour and I'd say I do two
and a half hours I sell out I follow
York guys who've had specials and and
all the club owners say it's great we're
gonna make our money back this week I
mean stop it and for two years I beg no
one wants to see a woman do an hour so
finally I met this guy you know when we
started going out and we got this
special in in the can and I brought it
and he said look that clearly they're
not going to buy you you have we have to
get celebrities and people hadn't used
stars as opening of their specials yet
they hadn't done these big numbers and I
got it was the week Cosby pardon the
expression became number one his show
brought back the sitcom saved NBC's on
the cover of
I had Cosby I had Letterman who had
never stepped outside his own show it
was the first year of his show he was
the biggest star in the world dr. Ruth
her first big year of fame had Larry bud
Melman it was so cool on Letterman Show
brother Theodore New York staple of
coolness and Tom Waits my friend gave me
his music and I went back up with and
with 12 years of honed comedy like
diamonds on velvet you know and they
went nope and they went oh so it is
personal because I had always said it's
personal and my boyfriend who produced
the show said you're crazy and when I
came back he said oh you're right it's
personal what do you want to do and I
said well what I wanted to do because
the way we got it done he knew everyone
in New York cause he had just shot Ruben
Ruben and Friday the 13th he said to
everyone we have $10,000 would you like
to work for $1 or would you like to get
all your money when to the shows sold
and they said Oh a lame Boozer it'll
sell you know so they all deferred and
he said what you want to do I said I
want to go on the road for one more year
pay everybody and get the [ __ ] out
because quit comedy change yeah yeah and
he said okay well we'll go up to San
Francisco I'll teach filmmaking whatever
I said good I'll make windchimes and oh
wow
yeah it was over and I finally went back
up they had started the cinematix comedy
experiment HBO which by the way did
write and direct two movies for them for
that but I went back up and they said
hey we got an offer for you we're gonna
buy your hour cut it in half and call it
the Cinemax comedy experiment and I said
I've been doing this for 13 years you
can go [ __ ] yourself I didn't take the
money and I went on the road and you
know the great saying is if someone in
TV doesn't like you wait five minutes
well it was actually a year but they
turned over a new young hip guys came in
took it up to show time they went holy
cow gave me four specials on this spot
and you know that was that we paid
everyone a year later and everyone
called and said we've never gotten paid
by anyone here later we're honest people
we're good